[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef with
globally inspired food and an
increasingly international reach born in
New Jersey Ken Oringer loved great
restaurants and after college decided to
make cooking his career he worked for
star chefs such as David Burke and John
George and had jobs in New York in San
Francisco before starting his own global
brand working with fellow chef and
business partner Jaime Bisson
Bissonnette their JK group runs Boston's
kapa and little donkey and their
best-known venture Toro a tapas bar that
now has locations in Boston New York
Bangkok and Dubai chef Ken Oringer good
morning welcome to the dish thanks for
being here morning guys so psyched to be
here this is quite a table and some
incredible presentation tell us what's
in this show well let's start with this
let's start with this is what we call
the one in the grapefruit which to have
people walking around a restaurant
carrying grapefruits to me is fun and
all our restaurants we just want people
to have fun and that's in the grapefruit
is funny obviously great food so this is
kind of a a play in a margarita but not
as sweet a little more interesting and
just something that sets the tone for
little donkey which is global small
plates which when chefs cook sometimes
they get bored with cooking like Italian
food or Spanish food or a certain type
of food so when people come over to my
apartment or Jamie my business partners
apartment we kind of just take whatever
we have and we wing a meal and we just
have fun cooking spontaneous really
eclectic food the things that you love
what do we have net fried chicken
sandwich that's what this is so this is
a Thai style fried chicken sandwich
where the chicken is marinated in pickle
brine there with the green papaya slaw
basically on a Martin's potato roll and
then we also have sweet potatoes with a
little bit of Molay and savory granola
we have cucumber salad with buttermilk
and tomatillo salsa verde and for a
holiday time I love serving clams casino
but being in New England we have the
best razor clams I think anywhere in the
world so we do
or clams Casino and then for dessert we
have profiteroles filled with matcha
which is green tea ice cream and then we
have pokey sticks which are these alike
so they shop things from Japan which I
think everybody's probably eaten pokey
sticks hopefully in their life and we
just basically crumble these on top and
then just kind of serve it where it's
kind of a Japanese Street foodie little
desserts now where does this come from
for you ever since I was a little kid my
parents encouraged me to cook and to
read cookbooks and it's something you
weren't reading always whatever you were
reading cookbooks at what age six years
old and watching Julia Child
Julia Child and reading Gourmet magazine
which my I couldn't wait for it to come
every time it came in the mail and and I
just was on his path I was obsessed with
food and I've kind of never given up
that obsession and I just love it still
so how does a Jersey boy master sushi
and Mexican food and Italian food you've
also have a Spanish tapas restaurant
it's a lot of traveling all my
restaurants have been pretty much the
product of my travels I think traveling
is the most important thing that any
young chef can do whether it be two
ethnic neighborhoods in your city or
your town or whether it be going
overseas or anywhere just exposing your
palate to as many different things as
you can creates taste memories which I
think are so important so when you start
thinking about food instead of thinking
about well I can use a little acid on
this chicken sandwich I'm just gonna put
lemon on it if you think about what kind
of acid they use in India for instance
you say well I'm gonna put am tor powder
which is a green mango powder that they
use in India for acidic touches you
could say well I'm gonna make a slaw but
I'm going to put my powder instead of
lemon juice and I'll give it a whole
nother dimension and we're always trying
to create food that has very unique
dimension you had a very successful solo
career and then you partnered with Jamie
Bissonnette and and you've had an
incredibly successful partnership what
why does it work and why did you just
decide to partner up it's I mean you
guys go way back right yeah we go way
back it's that you can only do so much
by yourself I think between the two of
us we have so much energy and we have
like a yin and yang you know he's this
guy with tattoos from head to toe
you know he's younger than me he's
almost like almost not quite like a son
but I mean definitely younger and and so
we have so many different approaches to
how we run our restaurants and how we
look at food and it's nice because we've
been working together for so long that
you can bring out so many more things
from each other because we're both very
critical and and we're not afraid to
take criticism which i think is the key
what is the biggest challenge though of
not being able to make it just what you
want you have to incorporate what
somebody else wants but sometimes you
can maneuver a little bit for something
that if it's like in a marriage if
there's something you really feel
strongly about you have to respect what
what your partner says about it you have
to say you know what I'll let you in
this battle but you know let's move on
to the next and and not make a big deal
about it well let's have you sign the
dish and I know your parents are here
with you so maybe they are the answer
I'm not certain but if you could have
this meal with anyone past or present
who would it be I mean I'm all about
family I've two little kids Luca and ver
van and and my wife Celine and to me
eating food with family there's nothing
better and that's why I first got into
cooking and and to me if I can have a
ton of food at a table the more people
the merrier and just family and and
friends and a big wooden fire cooking
and and I'm in heaven and plenty of
mezcal or injure thank you so much and
for more on can in the dish head to our
website at CBS this morning dot-com